Trascrizione: Giorgio Fighera
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Impatto sociale.
Se ne parla un sacco, no?
E allo stesso tempo,
non sappiamo bene di cosa si tratti,
è un po' una leggenda metropolitana:
non si sa come funzioni,
chi siano gli attori di riferimento.
E soprattutto,
perché sembra avere sempre più
a che fare con tutti,
invece che con pochi addetti ai lavori.
Una delle frasi preferite
su questo tema, per me,
è il fatto che l’impatto sociale
non più permettersi di essere solo giusto:
deve diventare efficace.
Infatti, se ci pensiamo,
i progetti sociali non hanno mai avuto
un gran movente funzionale, ma emotivo.
È una cosa recente,
quella di voler fare il buono e il giusto
in modo anche efficace.
Però,
quando guardiamo all'efficacia
dei progetti sociali,
iniziamo ad avere subito
un paio di problemi.
Il primo:
tutte le problematiche sociali
sono "wicked problems".
Significa che non sono problemi lineari.
Sono problemi complessi, sistemici,
che non sono risolvibili
né attaccando un aspetto isolato,
né da un solo attore.
Il secondo, la scalabilità.
Anche quando riusciamo a trovare
un progetto particolarmente efficace,
nel 90% dei casi
non ha una struttura
che gli permetta di arrivare
in tutte le località
dove quella soluzione è necessaria.
Questo è un problema.
È un problema perché significa
che, anche quando riusciamo
ad investire sufficientemente
tempi, risorse, ed energie
nel trovare una soluzione efficace,
poi ci blocchiamo
per modelli di diffusione obsoleti.
Questa dinamica
è ulteriormente alimentata
dal fatto che siamo ancora
attaccati a modelli reattivi.
Succede qualcosa; c'è una crisi; agiamo.
D’urgenza.
Cerchiamo di contenere i danni.
Con soluzioni frammentate,
isolate, mai coordinate.
E con inutili duplicazioni di sforzi.
Solo ora, grazie all'era
dell'informazione,
inizia a sorgere un nuovo paradigma:
quello proattivo.
Quello che dice:
ma se sappiamo come funziona,
se sappiamo cosa succede e perché,
perché non usiamo le informazioni
che abbiamo a disposizione,
dei modelli efficaci, e agiamo con tempo?
Per prevenire, il peggio.
Ma è davvero solo una questione
di risparmio di tempi, soldi, energie?
O c'è dell'altro?
La cosa interessante è che, oggi,
la psicogenealogia ci insegna
che i traumi provocati da crisi,
come l'Olocausto,
la malnutrizione cronica,
la violenza sociale
o la crisi dei rifugiati,
creano delle conseguenze sociali,
psicologiche e genetiche.
Si, anche genetiche.
È stato dimostrato che questi traumi
hanno conseguenze decennali,
che si trasmettono
di generazione in generazione
finché non vengono risolti o sanati.
Questo fatto ci mette davanti
alla consapevolezza
che fare sistema,
salvare risorse o prevenire,
o collaborare, o condividere modelli,
già non è un'idea carina.
Diventa un obbligo morale.
Sì, ma vi starete chiedendo:
"Chi è questa bionda,
che alle cinque di domenica pomeriggio
ci racconta queste cose complesse?"
Quindi, giusto per conoscerci meglio,
prima di continuare:
ho 28 anni; ho studiato
qui vicino, a Brera;
poi un anno a Bilbao,
e ho giocato 12 anni a pallavolo.
E mi sono laureata nel 2011
con una tesi su arte,
psicologia e sociologia.
Bel mix, no?
Lo penso anche io.
Infatti, quando mi sono laureata,
non avevo la più pallida
idea di cosa fare.
Mi sentivo persa.
La mia passione per il sociale,
per le politiche internazionali,
per la tecnologia, per la psicologia,
non riuscivano a trovare
un canale per esprimersi.
Uno spazio, ancora meno nel marco
della crisi generazionale ed economica
che conosciamo
ormai qui da dieci anni.
Poi per me è arrivato il 2012.
È l'anno in cui ho permesso
che la mia urgenza di trovare
il mio posto nel mondo avesse la meglio,
e ho iniziato a viaggiare
e studiare i modelli di impatto sociale
e di sviluppo sostenibile
in più di 20 paesi nel mondo.
Da Macao, qui a Milano,
a Bahá'í, in Israele.
Dal CERN, ai campi rifugiati
in Grecia e Macedonia.
E ho iniziato a notare qualcosa.
Un fattore in comune, una nota,
un elemento ricorrente
che accomunava le realtà
più disparate del Pianeta Terra.
E cioè l'insorgere di movimenti
che mettevano a disposizione modelli
che semplicemente avevano l’obiettivo
di permettere alle persone di agire,
ovunque esse fossero.
Tieni: questo modello funziona,
usalo dove sei.
Fai comunque parte di una cosa più grande,
di una causa più grande di te,
ma è molto importante
che tu agisca su scala locale.
Questa cosa ha iniziato a incuriosirmi.
Ho iniziato a investigare,
e ho scoperto che il valore
di questo modello
va molto più in là di quello
che io potessi immaginare.
È stato infatti dimostrato
che quando il nostro cervello è esposto
a eccessivi flussi di informazione
su crisi, problemi, traumi, tragedie,
sviluppiamo empatia.
Sviluppiamo una curva empatica,
e una conseguente necessità
di agire e reagire,
fare qualcosa in merito.
In poche parole, siamo disegnati
per vedere altre persone soffrire
e desiderare di porre fine
a ciò che provoca quella sofferenza.
Fino a qui tutto bene, no?
Invece, purtroppo,
è anche stato dimostrato
che quando questi flussi di informazioni
ci sovrastano e diventano troppi,
come oggi succede con i nostri telefonini,
i nostri computer o i media,
ci blocchiamo.
Il nostro cervello dice,
Non posso.
Non sei tu in pericolo diretto.
Mi stai sovraccaricando di informazioni
su problemi e cose negative,
e non mi dai
la possibilità di reagire
in un modo che io
possa sentire la mia portata.
E stacca la spina.
Le conseguenze le conosciamo tutti.
Isolamento. Distanza.
Apatia. Disinteresse.
Ignoranza.
Esclusione.
Intolleranza.
Violenza.
Questi sono fattori le cui cause
conosciamo molto bene.
Ed ero ad Idomeni, nel 2015,
quando ha capito che non possiamo
più permetterci di ignorarle,
perché intorno a me c'erano
[non] solo migliaia e migliaia
di rifugiati e migranti,
ma anche migliaia e migliaia
di cittadini e comunità locali.
E tutti con la stessa domanda in testa:
che cosa facciamo?
Da dove iniziamo?
Che cosa posso fare io?
Perché ho bisogno di fare qualcosa.
E così è nato ImpactOn.
Ho sentito l'urgenza
di creare un'organizzazione
che si concentrasse
solo ed esclusivamente
sul trovare, analizzare, selezionare,
progetti di impatto sociale
e ambientale esistenti, efficaci
e metterli a disposizione
di altre realtà in tutto il mondo.
Banalmente, siamo un ponte
tra il talento e il genio
dell'impatto sociale locale,
che mai potrebbe diffondere la sua formula
in tutti i luoghi necessari,
e studenti, imprenditori, università,
ricercatori, governi, imprese,
interessati in agire per cause sociali
e semplicemente bloccati
dalla complessità di questo settore,
o delle condizioni che li circondano.
Il progetto è nato un anno fa,
quando abbiamo deciso di lanciare
un primo pilota usando solo PDF.
Abbiamo scelto un progetto
che è Blood For All,
che permette di creare dei posti
di donazioni di sangue
in casi di emergenze,
in scuole o in palestre.
Era fondamentale per noi capire
come poter comunicare un progetto
non affinché venisse
semplicemente conosciuto -
quindi emotivo, fattore emotivo,
ma perché venisse replicato, funzionale.
Il progetto, in meno di tre mesi,
è stato replicato in 19 città del mondo.
Quindi abbiamo continuato a lavorare,
perché per noi è fondamentale scoprire
come per esempio usare i big data,
e domani il machine learning,
per rimuovere quanto più possibile
i colli di bottiglia dei processi attuali.
Abbiamo scelto un altro progetto,
in occasione della settimana
del cambio climatico.
che permette a qualunque educatore,
professore o attivista
di fare un'attività con dei giovani
in cui si evidenzia
la fondamentale connessione
tra quello che consumiamo tutti i giorni
e come ciò influenza il cambio climatico.
L'abbiamo lanciato un mese fa,
in inglese e in spagnolo,
ed è stato tradotto da comunità
in francese, in arabo e in portoghese,
e verrà usato in più
di 50 città del mondo.
E vi direte, chissà i budget di marketing.
Zero.
I budget di marketing, o l'advertisement,
sono la prima ragione
per cui conosciamo tantissimo dei progetti
che non necessariamente sono i migliori,
mentre gli altri rimangono nell'ombra.
Introvabili, persi per sempre.
È quindi per noi fondamentale
riuscire ad usare design,
psicologia dell'informazione e tecnologia,
per creare un paradigma alternativo.
E uno dei pilastri di questo
paradigma alternativo per noi
è quello che chiamiamo blueprint.
Un blueprint è una formula, la ricetta,
l'insieme dei componenti
che fa di un progetto
un progetto efficace,
la proposta di valore.
Quindi non usiamo più descrizioni
accademiche o emotive
del perché un progetto è buono e giusto,
ma perché funziona,
e quali sono gli elementi
da prendere in considerazione
quando una persona dell'organizzazione
lo volesse replicare
in qualche altro posto.
Per farvi un esempio,
una delle cose che specifichiamo
nel blueprint è la tipologia di progetto.
È un intervento?
È una cosa che dura
poche settimane, pochi mesi
o è da mantenere nel tempo?
Qual è l'impatto generato?
Qual è il valore?
Quale è la proposta?
Quale è il target?
Chi sono i beneficiari?
Quale è il grado di complessità?
Quanto è accessibile
ai famosi non addetti ai lavori?
Quali sono i tempi e le risorse
in media necessarie,
incluse per esempio leggi particolari
o permessi governativi?
Qual è la compatibilità di contesto?
In quali contesti è stato utilizzato,
quindi in quali altri contesti
c'è un'altissima probabilità
che gli effetti siano positivi?
E quali sono le avvenute replicazioni?
Un ulteriore riferimento.
Un'altra cosa che facciamo
è allinearci alle grandi agende
della sostenibilità,
come l'agenda 20-30
che sta marcando un nord
al quale puntare, tutti inclusi.
Ma non necessariamente
stanno dando delle formule
che permettano a persone e organizzazioni
di agire e cominciare a implementare
e raggiungere questi obiettivi.
Se penso a quella ragazza nel 2012, persa,
oggi so che ho incontrato il mio posto.
Perché tutti i giorni
conosco persone e organizzazioni
la cui genialità,
i cui progetti incredibili
fanno impatto sociale locale
ma non hanno mai pensato
che davvero arrivasse il momento
in cui potevano cambiare il mondo.
Un esempio? Ecoladrillos.
un progetto di un'organizzazione
in Argentina, in Cordoba,
che ha trovato il modo di costruire
con materiale locale
una pressa meccanica
open source, formula aperta,
e prendere PET sporco,
quindi neanche da lavare,
borse - plastica.
E fare dei mattoni.
Chiudono i mattoni tra le lamine di legno
con cui si fanno dei pannelli
per costruire case sociali.
Iper-isolanti, iper-resistenti,
iper-leggere.
100% costruite da donne,
da comunità vulnerabili.
Ma soprattutto,
un terzo più economiche
di qualunque prefabbricato sociale.
Questo è un progetto
che può fare la differenza
per la vita di persone
in posti dove c'è plastica
e assenza di case,
come per esempio nelle località
affette da disastri naturali.
Un altro progetto,
questo dalla California:
Lava Mae prende autobus
che non possono [più] circolare
per eccessive emissioni di CO2,
per esempio, o perché sono vecchi,
li svuota, li dipinge,
ci mette un bagno, una doccia
e crea dei posti mobili di igiene
che girano per la città
e permettono ai senza tetto,
non solo appunto
di avere accesso a igiene basica,
ma di fare un colloquio di lavoro,
o rivedere i loro cari.
O ancora, "Liter of Light",
che non usa solo
bottiglie di plastica riciclate,
ma ricicla cassette elettriche,
lanterne al kerosene, batterie,
e insegna a comunità locali,
vulnerabili, in tutto il mondo,
come usare i loro strumenti,
le loro capacità,
per costruire lampade solari,
lavorando anche non solo
sull'accesso all'energia
ma educazione, o sicurezza,
o accesso a wifi.
Questi sono progetti che potrebbero mai
diventare monopoli multinazionali?
No.
Le loro formule, però,
non avrebbero valore
in ogni singola località
in cui vengono replicate?
Io credo di sì.
E allora facciamolo.
In un momento di crisi storica,
con soluzioni dall'alto inesistenti
o che non ci rappresentano,
riappropriamoci della capacità di agire,
di creare,
di offrire alternative,
di creare un settore dell'impresa sociale
davvero efficace, davvero misurato,
davvero inclusivo.
Perché lo sappiamo
che girarci dall'altra parte
non fa che allontanarci
dalla consapevolezza
che non si tratta
di responsabilità sociale,
ma di opportunità sociale.
Perché sognare un futuro migliore,
e rendersi conto di avere
tutti i mezzi per costruirlo,
è la nostra più grande opportunità oggi.
Dicono che se vuoi puoi, e se puoi devi.
Quindi?
Qual è il vostro blueprint?
Grazie.
(Applausi)